et le climat donc au coeur de ce g20
mais pas uniquement les enjeux
politiques ont trouvé leur place lors de
ce sommet le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères est notamment revenu sur les
relations entre l'otan et la russie
entrent ou en direct pour en parler un
depuis moscou notre correspondante
reverra goffman
bon ben on verra alors quel est le bilan
de ce sommet et vue de russie
bonjour amiral les vaccins le climat
mais aussi les enjeux géopolitiques
comme ceux liés aux tensions avec les
etats-unis en mer noire ou encore
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien pour
la russie les résultats du sommet du g20
sont positifs a affirmé lors d'un point
de presse sergueï lavrov présent en
personne dans la cité éternelle ce
week-end en marge de ce sommet le chef
de la diplomatie russe a rencontré ses
homologues français et turcs chinois ou
encore italiens il s'est également
entretenu avec le président américain
joe biden un échange qui n'était
initialement pas prévu dans l'agenda du
ministre des affaires étrangères mais
dont les détails n'ont pas filtré une
des questions abordées par les
journalistes lors de cette conférence de
presse a été la rupture quasiment
définitive des relations entre moscou et
le temps avec la fermeture de la mission
permanente de la russie auprès de
l'alliance à partir du 1er novembre pour
sergueï lavrov le temps n'a tout
simplement jamais voulu de coopération
avec la russie je vous propose d'écouter
l'otan ne souhaite aucun aucune
coopération avec non nous avions des
représentants
et l'otan n'a fait qu à nous apprendre à
vivre à vouloir nous apprendre à vivre
et donc on parle de l'ukraine et s'est
donc il y avait cette propagande et ces
tensions et ces pressions exercées sur
la russie la question est close si
l'otan a une bonne raison de s'adresser
à nous
nous avons un ambassadeur en belgique
qui s'occupe de ces questions et le cas
échéant vous pouvez envoyer un signal
via le cloud bergues pour rappel les
dirigeants du g20 se sont réunis ce week
end à rome pour parler de la situation
sanitaire hier les copies de 19 de la
relance économique mondiale mais aussi
des problématiques liées au
réchauffement climatique
merci à vera pour toutes ces précisions